you know you've had quite a bit of
success have you ever been doing
stand-up and noticed there's like a
really big celebrity in the audience
that's gotta be destroyed I still get
caught off by I did a gig once in
Scotland and Prince William was there
that was pretty big but I did a gig in
the Melrose improv just popped by and
Paul McCartney was in the crowd oh my
god
and you freaked out and they go don't
freak out Paul McCartney's there I was
going down there to do new material I'm
not doing new material do my best stuff
Paul McCartney's dead anyway turns out
Sir Paul McCartney loves a good anal sex
joke he was like slapping his thigh
that's good to know may come in handy
and just write songs about love yeah
now who else anybody else well I I once
did another show that was similar to
this show and I say was Lopez Tonight
anyway so it doesn't exist anymore so
who cares and the other guest was Justin
Bieber and I was just sitting backstage
and was me and the Biebs and the Biebs
must have been about 16 super nice kid
he's mum's the same age as me because
she had him at like 16 or something like
that and I'm sitting there I got 11 year
old niece in Australia so I go look I
never do this to anyone but can I just
ring up my niece and if you could just
speak to her for just a second I'd be
the greatest uncle ever and he said sure
anything for a belieber he said it right
I love that so I got up in front of him
put the phone on speakerphone I rang my
niece a minister I was like midday there
I said how are you semi it's your
favorite uncle Jim now I know what a big
Justin Bieber fan you are and she goes I
hate him now I like one direction
[Laughter]
he can hear the whole thing and I was
like well he really wants to talk to you
he was super cool about it I think it
happened to him before
[Laughter]
you